so fourth graders used to learn Nevada
history in school so we got the lyrics
if you want to follow along for our
state song Home Means Nevada
[Music]
baby
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow Nate that's fantastic you're just so
talented I've been playing the flute
since I was in fifth grade and I urge
anyone who ever played in instrument if
you still have something hanging around
in the closet break it out it's fun how
many how many times do you reckon you've
played Home Means Nevada
in your years and not as many times as
I've played our national anthem I would
like to play Home Means Nevada more
maybe I'll surprise the aviators when
I'm supposed to play the national anthem
and I'll bust out Home Means Nevada
you're never coming back give them both
give them but I don't think they'd kick
you out no at all that's pretty
important well our state turns 158 years
old young on Monday but this has always
been the Friday now that we observe it
so and maybe there are a lot of folks
that have a holiday today kids get the
day off school Banks and some businesses
and Clark County and city government
offices all closed so it's like you're
enjoying your day today and that
three-day weekend but I don't think it's
a Federal holiday so we should get mail
today still getting my bills yeah
[Laughter]
that's almost over
almost not soon enough thank you for
joining us here on good day have a great
weekend enjoy everything we've got going
on and we'll see you back here on Monday
take care peace have a great
a little bit
[Music]